[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a este especial de
migrantes el programa semanal de France
24 sobre el Éxodo los saluda Juliette
riaño
[Música]
el título 42 ya no va más en Estados
Unidos la Norma que durante más de tres
años permitió la expulsión de millones
de migrantes bajo el pretexto de la
protección a la salud pública Finalizó
el pasado jueves 11 de mayo a las 11:59
de la noche el título 42 le daba vía
libre a las autoridades fronterizas para
expulsar a las personas que llegaban a
las puertas de Estados Unidos de forma
rápida y muchas veces privando a
aquellas que necesitaban protección de
su derecho a solicitar asilo en los días
posteriores se informó que los países de
tránsito como México y Guatemala
reforzaron sus medidas de controles
fronterizos con personal militar
mientras que en Panamá y Colombia
trabajan contra las redes de tráfico
Mientras tanto en Estados Unidos se
conocieron los primeros datos de los
cruces fronterizos tras el fin del
título 42 los días previos a la
expiración de la medida hasta Diez mil
personas intentaron entrar al país la
patrulla fronteriza reportó una caída
del 50% sobre ese número así lo informó
el secretario de seguridad Nacional de
Estados Unidos Alejandro mayorcas quien
además advirtió lo siguiente
de hecho ya hemos expulsado a miles de
personas que han llegado a nuestra
frontera Sur estamos aplicando nuestras
medidas tradicionales de control de la
inmigración en virtud del título 8 del
código de Estados Unidos y también hemos
emitido una norma que establece que si
una persona llega a la frontera Sur sin
acceder a las vías legales que hemos
puesto a su disposición o sin buscar
ayuda en uno de los países a través de
los cuales ha viajado entonces tendrá un
umbral Más alto que cumplir para acceder
a un asilo exitoso
las primeras horas del viernes justo
después de la expiración del título 42
suponían una gran expectativa no había
Claridad sobre lo que pasaría en la
frontera sur donde miles de migrantes
esperaban para poder pisar territorio
estadounidense France 24 estuvo presente
del lado mexicano del muro en Ciudad
Juárez nuestros enviados especiales
Andrés Suárez y Aurora nos reportaron
sobre lo sucedido allí antes durante y
después Qué pasó justo después del fin
nos lo cuenta nuestro equipo en la
frontera
el escenario de un colapso migratorio no
sucedió se tenía que por este el puente
internacional paso del Norte Como por
los otros puertos de entrada que
comparte México y Estados Unidos a lo
largo de su frontera se atiborraran de
migrantes con el final del título 42
Aunque eso no ocurrió también al frente
en la ciudad de El Paso Texas se
dispusieron albergues para recibir y
ayudar hasta 4.000 migrantes que
llegaran de súbito y aquí en Juárez se
prepararon con artículos de primera
necesidad desde la administración de Joe
biden se enviaron 1500 soldados Para
apoyar a las patrullas fronterizas así
como agentes de asilo para ayudar en las
oficinas de aduana pero para sorpresa de
la comunidad internacional y de los
propios estadounidenses todo transcurrió
con calma y normalidad de manera que se
barajan varias hipótesis y conclusiones
una de ellas es que los migrantes más
precavidos conocían que con la
implementación del título 8 tanto las
deportaciones como las sanciones más
severas que con el título 42 en cambio
otros migrantes y de acuerdo con el
cubrimiento que pudimos realizar no
conocían ni una política ni la otra y se
aferran más a un golpe de suerte cuando
se aventuren a cruzar la frontera hacia
los Estados Unidos en síntesis lo que sí
podemos ver Es que la gran mayoría de
los migrantes le apuesta a entrar a este
país norteamericano por una vía legal
esto a través de la aplicación cvp One
como también quedan unos otros que
descartan esta vía y contratan un coyote
o Traficante de personas poniendo su
vida bajo riesgo y después del título 42
se abre la puerta al título 8 una medida
que era aplicada desde antes de la
pandemia esta legislación supone
castigos más severos para los que entren
de manera irregular a Estados Unidos e
incluso dispone una prohibición de
reingreso al país durante al menos cinco
años Ramiro cuevar berena tiene los
detalles
tras la inspiración del título 42
vuelven a regir las normas prepandémicas
en materia migratoria queda en vigor el
título 8
se trata de una legislación que tiene
años de antigüedad y a diferencia del
título 42 permite que los migrantes
puedan realizar su solicitud de asilo en
territorio estadounidense sin embargo
bajo la administración de Joe biden se
modificó para que solo puedan ser
elegibles las personas que hayan
transitado a otro país pidieran Refugio
allí y no se le otorgaran además ante
una detención por un ingreso irregular
conlleva castigos más duros si alguien
llega a nuestra frontera Sur después de
la medianoche de esta noche Se presumirá
que no es elegible para asilo y estará
sujeto a consecuencias más severas por
entrada ilegal incluida como mínimo una
prohibición de reingreso de 5 años y un
posible proceso
la Esfera política estadounidense
continuó buscando endurecer las
condiciones la mayoría republicana de la
cámara de representantes aprobó el
proyecto de ley hr2 que impone límites a
los ilicitantes de asilo y les exige
pedir la protección desde fuera del país
también reanudaría la construcción del
polémico muro fronterizo
los republicanos en la cámara de
representantes aprobaron el proyecto de
ley de seguridad fronteriza más fuerte
que este país jamás haya visto asegurar
la frontera es una de las principales
prioridades y es la prioridad de los
líderes detrás de mí Estados Unidos
afrontará una nueva era que según las
palabras del presidente biden será
caótica en un comienzo una reforma al
sistema migratorio es aún una deuda del
Congreso y la inmigración irregular
vuelve al centro del debate a medida que
se acerca el próximo ciclo electoral en
el país
título 42 y ahora título 8
era comprobar Es que para muchas
personas en condición de movilidad
humana esas políticas cambiantes no son
muy claras ni influyen en sus decisiones
de llegada a Estados Unidos pero para
los que quieren pedir asilo de manera
regular la espera puede ser larga en la
frontera y mientras consiguen una cita
con los agentes migratorios
estadounidenses se las ingenian para
subsistir la historia desde el terreno a
continuación
en Venezuela jimera operador de equipos
móviles en una gran empresa luego que él
se estacione este espero que la persona
se baje para decirles Si desea lavar el
carro Oye desde hace un mes limpia
carros en un estacionamiento de la
fronteriza Ciudad Juárez Hasta que el
tiempo sea necesario hasta que me salga
la cita de sipeguán sin prestaciones ni
las garantías de un empleo formal Jim no
se queja lavando unos ocho carros al día
casi le alcanza para rentar un
apartamento con Los Dos Amigos con los
que salió de su Venezuela natal hace
tres meses
para las tres comidas
compro que sí media ropa interior
si me queda algo y un poquito que me
quede ahí que se lo envío lo envío para
allá para Venezuela ya el vehículo quedó
listo para que su dueño lo disfrute y
voy a lavar todos los carros que sea
necesario hasta llegar a Estados Unidos
con 20 pesos suyo amigo Alex de Haití
también decidió trabajar mientras la
aplicación cvp One le ha arroja una cita
con las autoridades estadounidenses
para mí si estoy viviendo Estoy comiendo
estoy mintiendo y mantener a mi familia
para mí esto América es mi sueño Sí pero
tengo poco paciente tengo paciencia y sé
que todos vas a dar bien porque si
estamos aquí por las gracias a Dios para
Alex tanto como para Jim las últimas
decisiones migratorias del gobierno de
Joe biden importan poco tienen la mira
puesta en Estados Unidos pero por la
puerta grande y mientras tanto buscan la
forma de ahorrar en México
no quiero irle que lo de entrar
legalmente y
en mi fe en Dios creo que vas a salir
puedes tardar puede ser bueno pero vas a
salir
este mes el secretario de estado de
Estados Unidos Anthony blinken sugirió a
los migrantes quedarse en México donde
según él hay empleos disponibles para
ellos sin embargo la burocracia para
trabajar como extranjero es complicada
por lo que Jim Alex y la mayoría de
inmigrantes no tienen más opción que la
informalidad
Ciudad Juárez es uno de los ocho puertos
de entrada legales para los migrantes
indocumentados que buscan ingresar por
tierra a Estados Unidos pero con la
entrada en vigor del título ocho se
endurecieron los requisitos de ingreso
Este es el reto para un joven matrimonio
de mexicanos que aspira convencer al
juez en una próxima cita de migración
huyendo del Estado de Guerrero en México
por la violencia del narcotráfico marco
y Rossi y sus dos hijos pequeños
llegaron a Ciudad Juárez para solicitar
asilo en Estados Unidos
en este momento voy a ingresar este
a la Apple One para ver este si tenemos
este cita
refugiados en un albergue cristiano Este
joven matrimonio se sostiene apenas con
la ayuda humanitaria que diferentes
organismos le entregan al albergue
cuando nosotros salimos del Estado de
Guerrero nosotros este Veníamos a ciegas
no teníamos este sabido nada del título
48 ni si el título 48 Ah el título 42 y
el título 8 Aunque desconocen que con la
re implementación del título 8 ahora es
necesario demostrar un miedo creíble de
persecución o tortura para solicitar
asilo tienen como justificación que
abandonaron su casa en el Estado de
Guerrero por la intimidación del cartel
nuevo Jalisco es el miedo que tenemos de
que nos llega a pasar algo Porque allá
donde en Acatlán de hecho este dice que
estaban matando a los niños y familia
pues completa y pues eso era nuestro
miedo que llegaran ahí nos hicieran daño
también a nosotros uno de los detonantes
para que esta joven pareja huyera de su
pueblo natal en México fue el asesinato
del padre de Marco quien se rehusó a
trabajar con los narcotraficantes y días
después sus restos fueron encontrados en
una fosa común del sector queriendo
salirse fue fue lo que se hizo que este
lo desaparecieran y encontrábamos sus
restos nada más
y tanto el temor Es que yo me suceda
algo así similar y que yo deje este a
mis hijos sin papá las esperanzas de
marco y Rossi están puestas en convencer
al juez de El Paso Texas cuando su cita
sea agendada pero como es usual en
Estados Unidos la ley está bajo la
interpretación del juez y será él quien
proceda a aceptar la solicitud de asilo
por rechazarla y ordenar la deportación
las nuevas normas inquietan a los
migrantes y a quienes buscan protección
y así lo en Estados Unidos sumado a las
reglas que ahora supone el título 8
habrá que ver cuál será el
funcionamiento de los centros de
procesamiento que Estados Unidos informó
se abrirán en países de tránsito como
Colombia y Guatemala
hasta aquí esta emisión de migrantes de
France 24 el trabajo en Ciudad Juárez
estuvo a cargo de Andrés Suárez
Jaramillo y Aurora bayut los invitamos a
comentar en nuestras redes sociales con
el hashtag migrante f24 sigan con más
información en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]